hatte ich bin wieder da wenn man sich
den weg
ja ich habe seit zwei wochen kein video
hochgeladen ja gut das ist jetzt nicht
wirklich lange aber für mich hat sich
das angefühlt wie eine halbe ewigkeit
ich hab natürlich auch eine
entschuldigung parat reallife ernst
hatte prüfungen musste an echt vielen
sachen aber und so ganz nebenbei ist das
noch passiert halt ein türstopper
gewonnen der deutsche web video preis
2015 in der kategorie kategorie newcomer
geht an die spritze aus marl war das
freut mich persönlich sehr sie hat nicht
nur kurzer zeit das bett video hat beck
real sondern auch die herzen der
community erobert vanessa i
in ihren videos setzen sich witzig und
gekonnt mit den themen auseinander die
jungen leute so interessieren und sie
hat
mini und smart die wir gerade gesehen
haben übrigens gedreht genauso wie die
anderen beim mini das ganze erlebnis
auch geblockt wie ein vorbildlicher
youtuber aber da das schon so lange her
ist und es ganz schön viele dateien sage
ich euch nicht alles ich präsentiere
euch nun einen kurzen zusammenschnitt
der schönsten erlebnisse des web video
preis gewinnt auch wenns verspätet kaum
viel spaß
zuschauer sind es ist schöne erstens
könnten sie mir bitte die füße putzen
dürften sie ihre schuhe putzen für die
frage wo ein kleid war das noch ganz
schön lustig schon beim eine dankesrede
bei anne wills wissen nagelneue wandels
nageln weil sie welche lackiert nämlich
gerade ihre nägel und kann deswegen
nicht überhaupt gar nicht schlimm wenn
ich mit diesem michael verband michael
schulte so wir können festhalten
vanessa mal wanne kann keine finger
lackieren ja aber gerade sagt und jetzt
jetzt vor die kamera an ist so ähnlich
kann das volk noch gesagt einziger ein
einziger streit ein einziges
davis ich bin mir kocht immer wieder
preise nicht habe den größten youtuber
deutschland gefunden in zukunft 2016
wird mein jahr
danke an alle berliner und angab
ja und mir bleibt jetzt nichts anderes
außer danke zu sagen für feedback danke
dass ihr immer dabei sein wenn es wieder
ein neues video ich glaube es motiviert
nichts mehr als wenn man so viele
zuschauer hat für euch und die einfach
den blöden größten blödsinn mitfeiern
ist es einfach cool
es ist einfach mehr gut mit dem was man
macht erfolg zu haben und spaß zu haben
und ich habe ja auch ein leben neben
youtube
aber das ist finde ich der bessere teil
von meinem leben
und da ich die meisten verpflichtung
erledigt habt bleibt mir halt auch jetzt
genug zeit dafür videos zu machen und
neue dinge zu lernen und ich freue mich
drauf und es wird so cool er mir auf
instagram und twitter schon folgt sieht
gerade las ich zurzeit mache rip steve
der keller sind sauber chef
das heißt chef bei twitter poste ich
auch mal super lustige sachen also boa
wenn ihr denkt meine videos schon lustig
sind dann rastet aus und bei instagram
mache ich auch sehr coole bilder und
dann würde ich ihr euch noch einen
schönen tag und wir sehen uns dann bei
den nächsten video mit ganz viel spaß
was
tschüss backen es zog mich an der backe
danke werden